yeah it's a Saturday during the damn
apocalypse I said that watching the
world and look at all the news and
everything I'm just laughing people say
in the world's ending their world might
be in and mine's just beginning I was
built for this [ __ ] I [ __ ] love it
evidently like Harvard got to a bunch of
trouble because when this lockdown
happened they didn't reimburse any of
the students even for their housing or
their to move tuition or anything
they're all pissed you know what I was
reading something about the other day
that didn't even occur to me I was like
[ __ ]
there there were people who were working
on cruise ships yeah during and when the
lockdown happened and they're still
there damn they let the they let the
passengers leave yeah but they wouldn't
let the employees leave so they're kind
of just stuck on this cruise ship so
yeah like it's on it's in the dock you
know I mean it's not out the middle of
the ocean or not them but it's like yeah
I was like oh [ __ ] I don't even think
about that we're supposed to be opening
up this week yeah we'll see how it goes
in Florida yeah I think Florida
Florida's done I mean there isn't a line
to get in there not do anything you know
we had to do like a line to get in in
the growth that's big you know over now
well that's because I think that was
just because it was the day before
Mother's Day and I was like really
really crowded because I cuz I'd been
there other times and I didn't have my
wait in line I think it was just because
and also because it was a Saturday we
usually go on the weekdays when it's not
as crowded yeah I think it was just
because it was day before because it
seemed like everybody was buying flowers
and balloons and [ __ ] like that yeah so
I think it was just because it was like
a heavy California California's falling
apart New York area is starting to fall
apart
[ __ ] people are saying [ __ ] it man
they want to go back to work they died
you know here's a good analogy to this
[ __ ] back in World War two the Germans
bombed [ __ ] London for like [ __ ]
months and people stayed locked up you
know I mean they were hiding down in
their dad bunkers and then they realized
that it didn't matter if you were in
that bunker or not you know bomb would
still fall on you you could get killed
and they died from starvation and
[ __ ] for the city falling apart
before they died from those little
[ __ ] pissant bombs falling on pea
so they just said [ __ ] it they just went
back to work pretend like it didn't
happen and the bombing stopped and it
them going out their work and it didn't
really well after a little while the
casualties they got over it they got
bored well I mean after a while it's
kind of like a you know damned if you do
damned yeah frying pan and fires
actuation so they just said [ __ ] you
think I went back to work it's where a
lot of that [ __ ] you know some of
those little slogans that they were you
know using and during during wartime the
British what was it you know was a Keep
Calm and what was it what was the one
that was real famous that they did
British people know what I'm talking
about
well now it's becoming like a meme Keep
Calm and whatever yeah yeah yeah Keep
Calm and continue or something something
like that keep calm and carry on carry
on I think it was it but um yeah cuz
carry on is just right it doesn't matter
you know I mean you're gonna die anyway
you know you're gonna die of old age
either dot you could die something we're
not eternal or immortal and you know if
you look at the average age of people
that are dying to this they were [ __ ]
in their 80s you know no you're not
they're not gonna collapse of
civilization over people who are on
their way out anyway because you're
gonna age out everybody ages out just
you know you got to be an adult and
[ __ ] accept that time runs low I'm
preparing for it I'm like a damn crow
warrior singing my death song okay
strong working out taking Psalms yeah so
anyway yeah we recorded a show last
night that's why oh and and I did the
shout out on the show but since the show
was probably not coming out till Tuesday
or Monday if you're a patron then I
wanted to shout out Jason because he
sent us while we were in between like we
were doing the break in between the two
halves of the show last night he sent us
a PayPal donation he still wants a shirt
we haven't gotten any good give him a
shirt I know we haven't got any shirts
done it's gonna be everybody's gonna get
shirts [ __ ] we know your name
we got it we was going to get the size
and some people I think I owe some so
it's like I'm gonna do a new design for
people that got some last time but then
I'm also gonna do like a couple of the
old design to give you to people so some
people will be getting like if they
getting runtime then I'll begin it was
like three it was light you know that
guy always sends his videos Rob Rob yeah
Rob Levinson he's like I you know I
never got a shirt and I said dude we
mailed you through email asking you what
size you wanted like a pause cuz he's
going back there to check his emails
like oh okay yeah yeah man we're not
[ __ ] you over we got to know what
your sizes are what sizes you want
because maybe it's not even for you
maybe it's a gift well that's why I
don't know what sizes you want that's
why I asked every time and you know then
once we know your sizes and everybody's
together that last one we did we gave
them a good two weeks I think yeah
getting all the sizes together and then
once we have all the sizes we go out we
go buy the shirts yeah or order the
short shirts we've actually found a
better online source I think I usually
either get them from jiffy shirts yeah
I'm not sure if they're back online yet
because I know they have like difficult
ly diminished your delivery because they
had like a lot of their people stay at
home you know see we gotta get supply
will be available so some people you
know like I promise table cuz he missed
some and I'm gonna give him some back
shirts yeah that's what I'm saying
tough like that so you know I'm glad to
work will take care everybody if you
give if you're if you're a patron sure
or if you get braces right or if you
send us money on PayPal you will event
you will get a shirt just tell us tell
us what size you want and then we got to
come on we got to come up with some
badass designs
I think the designs were kind of hit and
miss lately actually I liked them at the
time but then as they age I was like I
think we could have done it better but
part of that is the fact that I like
variety you know I mean once we have
enough designs I think it'll be more
satisfied yeah we need about like 10
different ones more work for me yeah
what had to make them all at once I we
just have to you know get more of them
out there we gotta start working on the
cookbook to you today I told you that
later on today cuz it's you know for
luck right now later on today I'm gonna
get the notebook and I'm gonna make you
come up yeah all the [ __ ] I've been
remembering more said I'm gonna put in
there because like I said if if I have
an idea of
what's going in there then I do like a
backup layout is reminded me some I have
a question for our European listeners
does barbecue sauce American style
barbecue sauce does it exist in Europe I
don't remember seeing it but then I
wasn't really looking for it either
yeah and that was like a long time as I
might include ways to make barbecue
sauce one thing that I did notice then
like I said this is probably different
now than it was when I was there because
it was you know at least 10 years ago
last time I was there but one thing
there was like a lot of you know
different cuisines and stuff especially
in the bigger cities didn't see a lot of
Mexican food though and I didn't know
I'm shown so I didn't know if Mexican
food it might be a bigger thing now
because the you know now that we have
like the bigger chains it shows I got
really a why not I got a recipe straight
from Tijuana but can my boy Jai here
sent it to me about how to make corn
tortillas yeah yeah oh you need corn
flour yeah yeah easy to make and there's
something I know I know a lot of
European people like Indian food I have
a lot of [ __ ] shortcuts with the
Indian that tell me that you can make it
home even right either number ready -
yeah you know easy way to make that just
don't throw some Rotel on a damn you
know we have something called rota which
is diced tomatoes and green chip and
they have it in all different like
flavors which you can get like a spicy
one you get like you know guin mild
whatever if you put Rotel just drain a
little bit of water out of it put wrote
in a bowl and throw [ __ ] like
cucumbers to flavor your salad and
dressing like ranch cucumber ranch
that'll that'll make ready to it yeah
that is a very close approximation yeah
especially if you put some cilantro on I
think the British called cilantro
coriander leaves yeah it's the same
thing I have to check but coriander
leaves yeah I'll make sure everything
translates properly yeah Lenny
measurements do yeah because somebody
asked about the Fahrenheit Celsius thing
it's like yeah we'll put both the
measurements in there and like you can
do we can do metric in you know yeah and
that way it's more international yeah
because then anybody can do it and like
I said I you know I want it to be like
specific to us and [ __ ] that we make
yeah and like
said you have some kind of like
shortcuts for things and stuff and you
can say like how to make it from scratch
or you know what [ __ ] that you use like
chicken chickpea curry I can make doubt
I can make palak paneer you do not
Pollak but it was SOG Pollock remember
that well saag paneer sabzi and SOG
Paula yes to you know with chicken and
and and and and SOG and paneer wassup
they can get I think they can get paneer
in England yeah your saag paneer is
really really good yeah
there's faster ways to me I love paneer
man I could just eat that all when you
find those recipes online they're
usually like this slow you know
meticulous way that somebody at home
would cook but in restaurants they have
a much faster and efficient ways of
making that yeah yeah making things in
one pot or only two pots instead of five
pots and then compiled into combining
you have to understand how they cook to
know what I'm talking about
and if you watch actual Indian girls
cook and are in Indian guys cooking
online they cook more like me a lot more
efficient using less pots because
there's that one Indian woman that you
watch on YouTube yeah I forgot her name
but I got her site a subscription to her
she she'll do it all in one pot that's
usually what we end up doing you show we
usually set this one pot and we make all
of them then we make the rice and the
other pot sometimes you have to blend
things II so that's that's the hard part
yeah like you know for instance like for
SOG you put hot water to pot start
pouring down fresh spinach in it until
it wilts and then you know I take my
little [ __ ] Cuisinart thing stick it
in an immersion blender
yeah the immersion and and do it right
in the pot throw chicken bouillon cubes
and the other fry in a frying pan I'm
frying up in oil onions and onions and
spices yeah and then add chicken to it
cook that about halfway and once it's
once it's doll done you throw it in that
other bottle yeah with some rotor
because we have this big like this hot
the girly profession that's like three
[ __ ] feet taller yeah I think it's
almost like a 8 gallon nine gallon pot
yeah we do that you could deep-fry a
turkey and a [ __ ] if you wanted yeah its
enormous it's a pain in the ass to wash
but it's enormous
that won't fit in the dishwasher yeah I
like a real pocket
big today you something if I gotta go
Alex Jones to eat my neighbor I can
[ __ ] heaven have a pot there hear him
do that I don't I don't pay attention to
that in my and I had [ __ ] as a
genius he knows exactly how to get to
get his genius he's a genius man he
works he's a [ __ ] genius
he knows exactly how to get mentioned
and in the newspapers he knows exactly
every time he gets mentioned in the
newspapers he sells more water filters I
guarantee you a humble water filter
salesman alright yes grifter well what
is grifton he's it's infotainment it was
so effective that CNN has copied that
model well they're doing the same thing
like personnel why whenever I have news
I just read it yeah I don't need that
them [ __ ] like ya get the news in
parenthesis with the news it's just you
know it's a product it's a news like
product yeah it's got to be entertaining
they're trying to compete with Bob do it
with podcasters and youtubers how's the
[ __ ] respectable News Agency get to
compete with people like us they can't
yeah I mean they have to go to Howard
Stern style actually how are stars
turned turned into [ __ ] kind of
irrelevant to reason you know that kind
of looked into what he's up to now he's
older he's old now and it's like an
audience is pretty much gone and he's on
that Sirius XM radio and that's having a
you know he's been on that forever yeah
and his shows kind of supported that
service pretty much yeah it was like
their biggest owner and his and its kind
of wavering right now but he was
recently just a year ago saying well if
it's on YouTube or if it's a podcast
it's not a real show you know you have
to be on radio to be on a real show
every time me and Jenny were on radio it
had no impact nobody heard it didn't you
know I mean ya know go tell that [ __ ] to
Joe Rogan that it that if you're not on
the radio you don't have a real show Joe
Rogan's [ __ ] got a huge show huge yeah
well like I said I was more reach than
any [ __ ] radio show there's just so
much competition now yes it's like so
many people have so many options
but yeah so so like I said later we got
a like cuz I I really want to get
started on this bucket yeah oh my god
because like I said I still got to write
my true crime book I'm still working on
that I'm still only on chapter 2 you
know I still got design work I got to do
I got to do all the show editing doing
the cookbook part will be easy it's just
mostly the outline coming up everything
I want to talk about then we got to
order we got to put it in order yeah in
sections and then once it's kind of an
outline then we'll just go from there
yeah and then I'll explain piece by
piece how to execute each one of those
in a most efficient way if you're at
home yeah I'm gonna assume that the
reader is not a professional yeah
they're just in it you know I mean well
yeah that's probably the best thing to
assume all right but you know to [ __ ]
with this you can have to have some
basic skills knife skills and know how
to run a cutting board you're gonna you
have to have a pots you have to have
pants you're just gonna need you know
you have to have some skills I'm
assuming that you have them did the
reader yeah I mean if anybody's gonna
use a cookbook then they're gonna have
it have some kind of stay would have
thrown up at least rudimentary writing
skills and this is gonna be kind of
sophisticated flavorful food from easily
easily sourced items you know I'm gonna
kind of focus on frozen and canned stuff
because I know everybody can get that
everywhere yeah and then substitutes if
I think that you might not be able to
get it how to make it you know out of
whole foods and everything can be
upgraded by replacing it with a whole
food you know you don't have to stick to
those ingredients you know I mean all oh
you know I mean you can modify yeah you
can play fast and loose which I do well
yeah I even play fast and loose with
certain purposes you got to taste it to
see that the everything's balanced right
might need more sugar might need more
salt well talk about that on each I mean
one thing I bought you like several
years ago I bought you Gordon Ramsay's
Indian cookbook yeah which is actually a
really good cookbook
although I will say that his recipes
tend to be on the mild wine but I think
that's because he did that on purpose
like so you know if you don't like
really spicy stuff like you can add
spice at your discretion but we did find
that a lot of the recipes like if you
follow
whose kind of thing it's like wow that's
like only like yeah this place that we
would normally but yeah at least a quote
I don't like really hot stuff I can't
eat really hot I don't know if it was
because you know it was written for a
European audience maybe he's dealing
with Germans and British people know
maybe they're kind of used to kind of
bland Rouge well I don't know because a
lot of the Indian food that is available
in at least in the UK is like really
spices you get a lot of people like that
but like it was like what we have here
yeah yeah I mean I always found that
okay and it's a lot easier to get over
there to rock like over you know over
here it's kind of like you got to go to
an Indian restaurant or idiot market or
whatever over there it's like even a lot
of fish and chip shops like sell some
Indian food here are Indian supplies
come from stores where India Pakistan
and Thailand are all kind of merged into
the damn store and sometimes Chinese and
there's like a little Chinese section
usually there's two kind of close to us
there are two rather large you know
Asian markets I guess you would call
them it's mostly Indian food and
Pakistani but then they have like a
little section of like you know Thai
stuff and maybe like a few Chinese
things like noodles and that type of
stuff one of them even has haven't been
at the other one in a while maybe they
both don't they both have like a pretty
small like pretty section also yeah yeah
they have produce there yeah it's not
like a huge like a massive grocery store
but it's just like a small like so
Horning in to execute those recipes
though that's what yeah yeah like you
know curry leaves and you know remember
the curry leaves yeah it's the funny
thing about it was that they for some
reason they always kept the curry leaves
like behind the counter yeah like they
didn't put it with the rest of the
produce so it's like because we were
always asking about it and she's like oh
we've got some and I was like why do you
keep him back there it's like drugs are
porn yeah
maybe you don't have that many it's just
like I thought that was really funny
they don't have them all the time but
it's like every now and then we'd ask
but you always have to ask just mention
in those matters that good nutty flavor
it really made a big difference I didn't
think it would um and like I said we
can't get them all the time because they
don't have I think the one place we go I
think they grow them yeah um you know
what I mean
for their [ __ ] French families and
their friends maybe that's why that's
why they're back there just for the
random people but it's like we asked for
Miguel about we go in there all the time
we're the only white people to go in
there pretty much so there's like yeah
yeah these give us anything
well [ __ ] that lady that works there is
looking she yeah she's a super cool
Nicki her name is trying to have
threesomes and [ __ ] yeah she keeps
wanting to come over another why maybe
it's not you maybe it's her yeah she's
working there laughter she's hilarious
hilarious but yeah so she'll give us
curry leaves as she had some but yeah we
haven't had any for a long time and they
really do make a huge difference if you
can get fresh ones like I said I think
they I think the family that owns that I
think they grow them that's why they
don't have them but yeah so we need it I
was trying to think of like a cool title
for it we'll have to think of a cool
title family-friendly title for it so at
least they could put it on a book show
and not be embarrassed and have some
[ __ ] hide it from the kids and put
the [ __ ] tape it's gonna have a
reasonable it's gonna have a reasonable
time the inside might be already oh yeah
[ __ ] right insides gonna be army
you're gonna read this [ __ ] you're gonna
hear my [ __ ] voice and accent that's
what I mean well I told you what you
should do is that you should just let me
record you talking okay then I'll just
transcribe it yeah okay it's probably
what I should that'll take longer but it
will get more of like a flavor all right
have you talking
also you know what I thought would be
super funny it's like if I could take a
bunch of pictures of you in different
like position like with your chef coat
on oh yeah guys you have one like
pointing at [ __ ] making a face like [ __ ]
this you know what I mean so I can just
like scatter that throughout the text
yeah we could put pictures of Pookie in
there too if yeah particularly if it's
like fish we can have her commenting on
on some of the recipes it's like taste
enough like feet
stinking of [ __ ] this stinks smells like
fish and fish guts she likes that she
loves [ __ ] Parmesan cheese yeah and
she likes feet man there's some dirty
yeah
dirty feet too because as soon as I get
out of the shower and go in the closet
like to get dressed she's like span in
between yeah put her snows in between
your toes and [ __ ] what are you doing
yeah like licking your - yeah yeah
trying to climb down in your boot yeah
yes like whoa all right so uh you guys
have a good rest of your Saturday yeah
have a fun Saturday night stay safe
whatever it is no [ __ ] what we're out of
booze we're totally out of it so that
booze I got whiskey well I got that
whiskey but doesn't mix of anything we
gotta go we gotta go do a little [ __ ]
man we gotta go to the [ __ ] liquor
store you tell me this [ __ ] earlier I
just realized that was thinking about
later on tonight cuz it's Saturday I'm
working we can't have it we can't have
Saturday goodbye okay I mean I can do
without you okay if you're in it's up to
you I mean you want you you want to get
out of the house all right
well I mean I have to edit this video so
I don't know how long that's gonna take
time to upload it it's for something
good time it closes at 8:00 okay go we
got to go get booze yeah all right so uh
you guys have a good day and we will
talk to you again tomorrow